hey everybody thank you for joining us
I'm Jess Cagle we are here to talk about
the morning show I love the morning show
which is an important show but it's also
monumentally entertaining anything that
has Jennifer Aniston and Billy Crudup
doing a duet from Sweeney Todd I am in
also for what it says about power in the
media equality everything that we're
talking about right now this show is
taking on all of those issues so you're
gonna see three short panels there are
there are about 15 minutes each and
we're gonna hear from Reese Witherspoon
and Jennifer Aniston along with their
co-stars and the other producers you're
all gonna see some you're also gonna see
some clips from the morning show so I'm
gonna bring in our first panel they're
here with me now they are Jennifer
Aniston Billy Crudup goo goo in bata rah
and Deshawn Kay Terry how are you guys
very well congratulations are they gonna
sing to do it right now yes I think
you're well aware that that was all a
recording we actually do recorded the
entire show so we that's gonna that's
what actually this whole hour is my
entire performance was dubbed by going
close so I would be so happy with that
entire show by the way Jennifer I want
to I'm gonna start with you to start
with you to talk about Alex levy the
some of the things that you know
fascinated me about Alex are she you
know struggles in this male-dominated
environment she struggles in her life
she struggles with Fame she struggles
with her own complicity in because she
feels she helped create this environment
what was it what was it about her that
intrigued you the most when you first
started thinking about this character
and as the show evolved from the
premier through the finale and the
scripts came in what surprised you about
her evolution well first of all
everything that you just listed is what
intrigued me about her and to be a woman
in this day and age and and
understanding the once I really got in
and understood the world behind this you
know machine of monpa and our sort of
comfort zone every morning when we wake
up I was I was I mean what intrigued me
about her was how complicated the and
and how she was able to kind of manage
all of these spinning plates while being
completely able able to compartmentalize
each plate that she spun and when she
got on camera and spoke to America and
you would not have a clue of that her
life was kind of crumbling around her
and that was something after speaking to
a lot of incredible people that allowed
me to talk to them when I when we were
doing our research that's what you can't
you can't have there's no world there's
no world in which any of your life
matters it's just really all about you
know America and that ability to kind of
compartmentalize it was astounding to me
and also the drive to keep that
relevance for as long I mean to really
love that job so much that you for 15 25
years in some cases or longer will wake
up at 3 o'clock in the morning live this
sort of vampire lifestyle and love the
news that's that much that you can make
that kind of those great sacrifices the
other part was as as the as the scripts
came in and the show evolved and as your
performance involved evolved and your
take on the character what was there
anything about Alex that surprised you
by the time we got to the end
I mean I don't I'm not really sure if
anything suprise I just loved
I enjoyed every turn Carrie Aaron took
with Alex
III nothing actually surprised me I
think probably and I think because we
also were in constant communication Reis
myself Carrie and the riders about where
this show sort of was going to evolve
from the beginning to the end so we were
we kind of had an idea of where we where
our characters would be going so there
was nothing that really surprised me so
much but I think what was really just
surprising honestly was just how how
exciting it was to be a net this wasn't
a surprise I felt it from the minute we
started doing it was just how exciting
it was to be a part of this project at
this time in in the world where all of
this was happening around us and being
able to be a voice for so many women and
and speak and feel that Fury especially
towards the end of the of the series
where when they just kind of lose it and
just that shame of knowing that you
stood by for for so long just because
you know well how are we gonna beat that
how are we gonna beat corporate America
we're just a bunch of women we won't
have a voice and yet it turns out you
actually do and it takes a movement I
mean just being a part of a movement is
quite incredible so Gugu I assume that
you knew a lot about Hannah and her
mindset and the the trauma that she went
through from the very beginning you knew
that the audience of course did not in
the early episodes what was it like to
build that character knowing what you
knew about her but to the audience and
to the other characters she seems okay
how did you how did you inhabit that
character knowing her trauma but giving
her the face that she gives to the rest
of the world
yeah well Carrie Aaron our showrunner
and Mimi leader as you say talk to me
through the whole arc of Hannah's
journey from the outset even though I
hadn't read all the scripts and you know
I always feel and I think you know most
actors would agree that the most
interesting characters to play are ones
that have secrets and so for me it
really charged every scene for me even
if I didn't have a lot of dialogue or
you know that that I knew I had I always
had something to feel and I always had
something to think about the situation
and as in life you know we're always
concealing our trauma where we always
want to look like we've got it together
and you know I think obviously for
Hannah she definitely had the the sort
of bomb of her career which she was you
know to bury good at her job
very ambitious very driven and she was
really using that to as a form of denial
really so so yeah I found that
fascinating and I think you know the
little moments that we talked about you
know early on in in the show
specifically scene where you know Hannah
goes and visits Ashley Brown for example
and tries to sort of lure her onto the
show and and there are moments there in
the script that you know knowing
Hannah's internal motivations and
talking to me about how to play that or
how not to play that you know that she
was actually you know somewhat living
vicariously through Ashley Brown that
this meant so much to her in some ways
because you know through Ashley you know
who could expose Mitch and talk about
Mitch on the show she was able to kind
of feel that that was you know something
personal to her so that there are little
moments like that you know and when
Mitch comes back into the studio to sort
of plead with with everyone you know
everybody's thought process obviously is
very personal and different so um so
yeah I think you know and and for me
obviously you know as the series kind of
went on get getting to really you know
unleash all of that stuff with the you
know the flashback episode in Episode
eight was really special and I was kind
of chomping at the bit
you know to get to the meat of her story
so so yeah it definitely made it
satisfying for me I forgot to say in the
very beginning I am gonna go through
this because we're all remote I'm gonna
ask you know I'm gonna direct my
questions to you individually but
anytime you have something to add to
somebody's answer or whatever feel free
to jump in and feel free to interrupt me
all you want
Billy Corey is sorry I didn't take Mugu
in that episode was so absolutely
phenomenal and heartbreaking it still
give by the chills and tears and I've
watched it so many times I mean all of
you have obviously but that was so
delicate and really so beautifully
handled and my god I mean I've chills
right now I just wanted to give you a
very large shout out to that
extraordinary performance that means so
much I've gone back and watched a few of
the episodes and when you know what has
happened and you to all of them to all
of you and and when you go back and and
and look at that performance or an
actor's performance knowing what you
know about them and knowing the secrets
they get unveiled later it's really
remarkable how all of you kept all of
that end it's it's it's a fascinating
courage a second viewing of the show
Billy when we start with I I just didn't
know what to make about Corey I think
now I maybe got him figured out a little
bit why I think he's I think he's a good
guy but for the most part but in the
beginning we just don't you just don't
have any idea so I'm wondering and part
of the fun is he keeps everybody enough
balanced that's his that's his power
right whoever's with him so how much did
you know about him going in
did you know everything about him or did
you learn stuff along the way like the
rest of us did well I probably knew a
little bit more um but just to echo
Jen's sentiment real quick when the
first thing I thought when I saw goo goo
and we we did some press after
the after the show came out and
everything but the first thing I thought
when I saw is oh so happy to see like
like she's not dead like that character
you know like which is so painful and
like in my memory I was like oh my god
you look so great for being dead and all
that but no can I say I'm I'm haunted by
what the moment in the in the bedroom
but also the smoke on the cobblestone
when she disappear it's so so
heartbreaking and is it's really
haunting and and when you're acting
right I mean should haunt you it's that
kind of thing that not only haunts a
person's life but haunts the community
around you and it's inspector of that
kind of intimidation that creates a
culture where people don't know how to
behave in the way that they were taught
when they were younger like how do we
did the Golden Rule let's just start
there you know how about things that are
obvious to all of us they become so
confused and and and they're manipulated
by people who like to be in positions of
power kori is a person who likes to be
in a position of power and one of the
ways that you manipulate um I don't know
if you've watched the news but just keep
people guessing about what's next and
you keep people so discombobulated and
Confused that meanwhile you work
underneath to establish rules that you
think are gonna ultimately benefit you
and and I think Corey even though we
don't know what his motives are
underneath whether or not there is any
kind of moral ethic um he has a very
clear sense of purpose and whether that
sense of purpose is judged after the
fact is being psychopathic or
magnanimous or he knows he has an
opportunity as a person who is in a
position of authority and someone who
the system has already promoted just by
virtue of being a white man he knows
very
well that that's a place of power and he
can't stand the dudes that wield that
with the kind of thoughtlessness and
lack of empathy and that to me was
carries like hidden secret that she kind
of let me into with references to Cory's
mom early on because I would say to her
what is that about and she said he was
very close to his mom really important
to him that he supports women in the
workplace
and so for the him to be able and I mean
one of the bait and switches is he
thinks Jen's character at the beginning
just isn't interested in the game
anymore which pisses him off he's like
get in the game you're in a position of
power when he realizes then that she
actually has that motivation but it had
been like suppressed by years of this
you know systemic oppression um he's
like sweet let's get on the team what's
right let's go let's take this stuff
down and so that to me was a winning if
if not a convoluted approach to
unveiling a person's moral ethic it was
a good reveal Deshawn wait you know I
didn't say that I want to see Cory's mom
anything's possible so deshawne you play
Daniel the weekend anchor which enabled
it enables the show to explore what this
environment is like for another kind of
person a black man trying to navigate it
trying to you know move up in this
environment did what do you think was
going through Daniels mind as you
thought about the character and
inhabited that character he's in that
environment what is going through his
mind
um well you know Daniel is he's so
ambitious and I think that you know that
what's fascinating about the workplace
is it's this first it's a glitzy world
right because you have cameras and then
it's such this capitalist world and
Daniel makes it very clear from the very
beginning that he he comes to play and I
think what's also fascinating about or
one of the things that really I really
have fun with with this character and
with this world is that we because I do
count them as artists journalists
they're communicators so that means that
we're we're deeply empaths and so you're
connected and so I think it's it's
really interesting to see the dynamics
between the things that make them human
and the things that oh this is my
ambition speaking or you know that
moment when you know I really love how
where the series ends because you know
Daniel is in a point of conflict and
then we see this brave act being done by
Alex and the question has been well
what's going on through food annuals
head at that point in time I think at
the base of all of our our characters
for the most part we have moments where
we what we don't trust them but I think
one of the things I love about the show
is that at the base of the characters
you can see that there's something good
about them and I believe at that moment
Daniel just feels the the the pain and
empathy of what he as a man has also
been supporting because he is not guilty
out of this all of us have different
types of privilege right so there's
different types of privilege that he has
in that moment and in that structure he
did contribute to that but also as a
black man he is the one who is
experiencing really and truly the the
lens of oppression based off of color
because it is a very very colorized
world where you don't see people like
him at the anchor desk and I think it's
really brave and amazing to have a
character like that who's speaking out
front about it and so purposely is
trying to change the world and just
getting his viewership does change the
world just seeing that image changes the
world and Daniel is very much so
aware of that power and he wants to
wield it I think to create that image
that he wasn't able to see when he was a
young kid because he knows how powerful
that can be to a viewer Jennifer and
Billy whenever whenever you were doing
the Sweeney Todd duet talk where you're
sitting there you're having given your
relationship you are really rivals at
that point and you are singing to each
other you know obviously a song that
says nothing's gonna harm you not while
I'm around I was so curious what you
thought those characters thought during
that song because they they're both
smart people they must have seen the
irony in what they were singing but
where they also may be wanting their
relationship to be that way but it's not
what was what do you think was going
through Alex and Cory's head I still
don't know but I mean I think it was I
think there there was there's an extreme
mutual and admiration for each other in
terms of who they were at their both I
think they know she knows what Cory's
all about and he knows what Alex is all
about but there was something very
bizarrely seductive about the entire
that that interaction that was sort of
you you've got to take away whatever it
was that you wanted to take away your
imagination could just kind of you know
have at it
but I think it was just sort of a dance
you know it was like a sparring of you
know with each other
it was very fueled but yes it was kind
of up to a I'm still very we're still
very back I am still for us watching it
in the room and we saw it yeah what do
you think were like day by the bomb it
was very confusing it was rich I want to
hand it to all of you I know that you
you know you were all talking about
googoos performance and I noticed in the
in the finale you know you hear or say
the really throwaway line you didn't
make a lot of this where she says it
didn't kill me and knowing what if you
if it's a second viewing and you know
what's happening that is a is a really
shattering line and and I have to hand
it to all of you great show great
performances thank you for it I've now
watched it twice but I'll watch it again
anyway we are we're out of time and
we're gonna have a clip and then we're
gonna be back with our next panel I
didn't know his club that you told me
would never change what about that
is it I said it I didn't realize help I
just
by no Fred Lee I cannot do this I need
you to what do you think you need 24/7
because them in your living room every
morning trying to make you feel better
about this miserable world difficult
night guess what Alex I'm empty this is
empty stop it out of empty you know
empty looks like it looks like this what
I say no no but will you just calm down
I will go upstairs you shut the I just
give him his bag give this phone back
home sir come on welcome back now on
this panel we have Reese Witherspoon
we have Kerry Aaron we have Karen
Pittman and Mark Duplass Reese I'm gonna
start with you and in the finale I
really wanted to ask you about the
scenes that you have with Gugu and
basarat' where Bradley is learning the
extent of her of her trauma but she's
also trying to do her job because
Bradley among many other things is a
true journalist in the best sense of the
word and I wanted to ask you how you
approached those scenes and how you walk
that tightrope between having compassion
and getting her to do what you need her
to do oh yeah I I actually that's a
great question because I think we've all
been thinking a lot about having
[Music]
trauma-informed conversations right I
think we're we're walking through a
space right now we're basically everyone
we're encountering is dealing with a lot
of trauma and Carrie it's weird sorry
Carrie and she's sitting right here and
go ahead you know I mean she just writes
brilliantly to the nuance of those kind
of conversations right so and and and
there's different tracks going on at the
same time
my characters a journalist she's trying
to get to the truth of this sort of
corporate disease that exists within our
network but she's also thoughtful about
goo-goo her characters experience but if
she is she really being thoughtful about
goo Goo's trauma or is she sort of
serving her own ideas and and and trying
to fulfill her own needs so I think
we'll see as the show ends and then as
season two begins what does it mean to
charge forward with your own needs being
more important than understanding
someone else's drama Carrie because
because we have you here and I want to
go straight to the source
I just want to ask you directly what
does this show say about power when what
does it say about how we as a culture
reckon with inequality in our culture so
I need like an hour sa pencil to answer
that that's right
break it down a little bit for me give
me the first part what what did you want
to say with the show the show is about
power it's certainly about me too but it
really is at the heart of it it's about
power and I'm sure that we'll see that
play out in the second season but what
did you want to say with this show about
power or the empower power you know I
guess I my feeling about power is that
it's it's it's the strange thing that
attracts all of us and usually leads us
off a cliff that it isn't necessarily
feeding any good part of you but it's
linked to some sort of survival thing
that we left you know thousands of years
ago but the power in itself just has
this like magical seduction to it and we
just get focused on it at the expense of
everything else and just and just
I toured it at all at all costs and I
think you know it's in that sense it's a
um it's a morality play you know that's
don't let this happen to you when you
were you know just starting the first
season the the conversation about me too
erupted many people were suddenly very
publicly held accountable for for
misconduct and and worse and right now
as you're going into the second season
another cultural conversation is
happening long overdue about race how is
that informing or changing what you're
going to do in the second season we're
working on the second season because we
had the time basically to kind of go and
dig in and reinvent it a little bit and
we're figuring figuring all that out
I said recently that you like creative
people are just we just absorb
everything and then we and then we
repurpose it so that's what we're in the
process of doing I mean it has been a
huge huge i opening and emotional time
that i think is going to be present and
so many artists work one of the things
that is so great and compelling and
interesting about the show is that it it
takes on all of these issues of power
but it it not only doesn't shy away from
the gray areas it really runs toward
them and karen you and Mitch your
relationship at least from what I can
interpret from the show was a very gray
area and when you learned that she had
had that your character had had a
consensual quote-unquote relationship
with Mitch how did you respond to that
did you think oh my
gosh this is a terrible message or oh my
gosh this is a really interesting kind
of relationship to look at no it's
absolutely interesting that's very
challenging I love a challenge though
and I fight again the writing staff and
Kari Aryan I thought they handled it
beautifully in the nuanced way I mean I
think that no woman is not familiar with
a very charismatic predator right that
is essentially what Mitch Kessler is the
most charismatic man you would meet and
the synergy of when he starts to prey on
you you just really you really don't
know you know I often would reach out to
carry every couple weeks and we'll call
her like on the weekend or some moment
where I know she was probably busy doing
something else or text her and say hey
carry this Mia find her way out of it
this episode characters we were all
under the gun we were all under this
emotional incredible emotional weight
this gray area which I thought was just
this of course I sort of exploded in in
episode 7 for Mia but there's so many
different variations of how this worked
for each character that had been
affected by Mitch Kessler Ashley brown
and Hannah Schoenfeld and of course Alex
levy so yeah but for me it was a
particularly gray area but I didn't find
that it was handled any subjectively or
judgmentally at all it wasn't like we
were wagging a finger at her we really
were thoughtful about what her character
arc looked like throughout the season
for me the one of the most one of the
most shattering scenes is when Mia and
Alex are sitting there and pointing
fingers at each other because you
realize the toll that that this kind of
environment takes on people when these
you know two people that should be
allies are suddenly sort of pitted
against each other it's really powerful
mark you play chip obviously who is a
you know he's a straight white male
very much part of the system he is he's
a company man but he becomes an ally by
the end what what can you tell me about
his evolution chips evolution and what
he learns and what he has what the
character has to say to men particularly
straight white man in the workplace
that's a great question you know and
it's become a more complex answer since
we've made the show and I don't know
that I have a full handle on it but I
know that at the time when we were
making the show one thing that really
appealed to me about chip and and you're
right being you know straight white male
cog in that machine is that I think chip
fancied himself at least 10% downstream
towards the good side of how a man in
that position of power could be he was a
pretty good boss to to the women he was
pretty good to people and and that was
enough for him in that moment and what I
think the show did so well is that as
the Miche movement came barreling
forward at an exponential speed he found
out that his 10% down stream was
woefully behind for human standards and
I think because he is a decent person it
threw him into emotional turmoil into
existential turmoil and I think that he
had a lot of catching up to do in order
to become an ally and to and to I guess
reckon with his complicitous in that
part of the problem even though he was a
better version of one of those white
powerful guys and I have to say I
identify with that more than ever now in
2020 as I think about my own place and
as a person who runs a company and what
story do we want to tell now and I've
always considered myself to be mostly on
the right side of things and now can
really see chip and feel him and say I
was close but we're all behind and I
think that one thing this show was oddly
prescient about was when the wave comes
and it can't be stopped it comes at a
speed that none of us are prepared for
that's not a bad thing you just got to
be willing to be honest and
shift and I have no idea Carrie how
you're gonna handle that 42 sighted good
luck the conversation about racial and
gender diversity in castes and on crews
is relatively new I mean it's been had
in earnest it's being had more in
earnest now but over the past couple of
years it's been had in earnest do you
find it easier now has it gotten any
easier to find the people that you want
to hire and to make sure that the people
with the money allow you to hire the
people that you want to and that's a
great question I have been I mean
working in the Hollywood world for
thirty years and I've seen enormous
shifts in the past three years and I
have to say like I found a lot of
strength through the times up movement
by other women who are super aligned
with trying to find equity in our
workplace and that's really
intersectional work that I had never
experienced before in our business and
really understanding that all of those
things were possible part of what really
inspired me to was working with ava
duvernay on on wrinkle and time and the
work that she had done behind the camera
to make sure that the crews are diverse
and that we were you know how wait what
story you tell is just as important as
how you tell the story what are what are
each of you and I carry this will be
harder for you to answer but each of you
tell me what relationship or aspect of
your character you're most excited to
explore more in season two I'll start
with Karen yikes are you I think the
aspect that I'm most interested in
exploring is you know Nia walked through
season one with a great deal of always
walking into a scene with Mia
to carry the motivation of I am going to
turn this conversation around about what
happened with Mitch in every moment
whether it was with Alex or with Bradley
or with Cory or with chip
it was always in some kind of response
to I need to fix this thing that I did
it felt like every response every thing
that she was challenged with was in some
somewhere in her behavior was a response
to this mistake that she made this
self-inflicted wound so because she
addressed it in Episode seven so well
and we took her all the way through to
episode 10 I'm interested what it will
be like when Mia is not actually every
single thing that she did in the back of
her mind wasn't bad stuff that she did
with Mitch Kessler do you know that's
going to be interesting for me to see
what what her emotional landscape is
going to look like for season two no
pressure carrier no you won't be
disappointed and mark I'm I'm really
confused about chip like is he gonna be
back what's gonna what what's gonna be
happening with chip or what do you want
to what are you excited to know about
listen I I know some things I don't want
to say anything cuz you know I don't
want to ruin it and who knows what the
hell carries rewritten at this point but
I I will say that what I love about chip
is that he is very is very nimble he's
good at being on his feet he's good at
convincing people of things but but he's
a lonely guy when it comes to his
interpersonal relationships as a massive
black hole there and I'm looking forward
to seeing that little Achilles heel of
his as it affects not only his work life
but you know that that real
vulnerability of someone once they allow
themselves to get close to someone and
and how that really is wonderful but
also sends a wrecking ball into your
life sometimes Greece what about you
what about Bradley ah I just love
Bradley so much she has this
hair-trigger temper that is just so fun
to play and this truth-teller
sensibility that she
wishes she could stop but she just can't
and I relate to that so much I have a
big fat mouth sometimes I'm glad to know
that that won't stop us all um no and I
love what Carrie explores with power and
how that affects people and what what is
power right and what is ego and and what
do you do with power right once you have
it I think I'm really excited to see
that because Bradley is maybe gonna
explore having a little more power in
her life thank you guys so much karen
pittman mark Duplass Carrie Aaron reese
witherspoon we are going to be back with
our next panel right after this clip
from the morning show I chose you and
everything is on the line for me
we have an opportunity to do something
truly meaningful we're the running show
we can do anything it's my whole life
you can't ask me to not fight for that
we're in the middle of an epic rebirth
[Music]
all right our next morning show panel we
have mimi leader michael elenberg nestor
carbonell and brian Stelter these are
for the smartest people that are working
in Hollywood I have to say it's just
just so happened that the four of you
are right exactly he did don't let it
fool you I please don't pester if he
hadn't mentioned that you had gone to
Harvard would you hit on it in your
first answer well you know if I hadn't
Mimi sorry that may not mean it but but
I know carry her and what if she made
fun of it the first episode of our show
it was about dropping the drop it was
like they call the bar behind Harvard
yeah Harvard Harvard Harvard it was
called dropping the h-bomb I learned
quickly that up you never bring up where
you go to college because no one wants
to hear it
Mimi I'm gonna start I'm gonna start
this panel with you so you directed for
the episodes hired all of the other
directors you are the supervising
director this was a show that you know
had such gigantic expectations it was
Apple it was two of the you know biggest
stars on the planet it was it was about
something that everybody was talking
about I know that you must have had a
tremendous amount of input from a lot of
different places as you were you know
directing these shows how does a
director take all of that input and then
maintain a really cohesive vision for
the show which it has it's one of the
things that's so great about it but also
then you know hand it off to some other
directors for for a lot of the episodes
well you know I was there you know from
the very beginning you know before a
script was even written you know I was
always interested in this world and I
read Brian's book I had dinner with
Michael and I was in and when I
developed the look for the show I I
wanted it to have a very strong visual
style
I obviously in the morning show light
on us on a morning show set it's very
bright it's very clean it's kind of
perfect but our world is a very messy
world and has and a lot of you know
saturation so I wanted it to be very
colorful I wanted to shoot the women as
you would shoot a man you know with big
close-ups because a lot of dps they
don't want to shoot they don't want to
go in there and and go tight on women of
any age because it's like no no it's too
tight you know stay back and I really
felt that this was such an exploration
of hate this expression but two very
powerful complicated women and so I
wanted to do big frames where you see
the character character of the city next
to their faces and so you go in and you
create a pilot you create a look and
what you hope for when you hire other
directors is that they honor your style
and they do and you hope that they make
it even better you know because I
decided when we started this show that
there were going to be no visual rules
because sometimes you go in and you make
a show and you say okay we're not gonna
do any handheld shots well this was a
completely different you know approach
we could do handheld we could do cranes
we could do steadicams we could do lock
off so we could do long lens it was all
about what the scene was about and how
to best tell the story visually and you
know it it was a very detailed look this
season and how sexual assault happens to
to one of our characters and you know to
shoot that you had to really get in
there and get in there emotionally with
the camera and so that's what I tried to
do with the show and I think that's what
how it was written and yeah it was a
great exploration maybe you know mimis
Shepard all of our directors include
dear friends of ours Lynne Shelton who
did really a wonderful job for us on the
fourth episode so and so we're worse
we're heartbroken about her her untimely
death and absolutely it was shocking and
and and she brought you know her indie
cred to the to the show and and really
put her stamp on her episode you know
she and that's what really great
directors do they come in and they do
something special and they make you pay
attention and you sometimes don't even
know why and that's the best outcome
Michael one of the things that is so
interesting about the show and really
bold of the show is that we we hear all
of these various male perspectives so
for example you know for example Mitch
thinks he hasn't done anything wrong I
think the great line is from the dawn of
time men have used their power to
attract women and now he's just angry
that you know the rules have changed
and that he's being treated unfairly but
for the for the creative team and the
writers was it difficult to you know get
into the head of a chauvinist and then
present what he's thinking and make him
human without excusing his behavior or
his worldview but because you do manage
to do that and I just wonder what the
what the creative process was like and
getting to those to those places in the
scripts yeah I mean obviously Carey
could speak best to it but the show and
really her I'd say emotional thematic
and kind of vision of the world not just
the show is you know the show is a very
clear moral point of view but inside
that her real desire was for not to have
a show where for the audience to feel
safe you know where like the you
shouldn't feel like three years ago
everything was fine and you were good
you know and here's someone
clearly bad and like that didn't feel
like a thing that would have addressed
the reality of where we were and be a
kind of honest reflection that would
yield real growth and you know real
depth and meaning going forward so there
was always a desire to show humanity bad
people we could do horrible things in
the show and people do good things in
the show and have a real reckoning for
all of us watching at home which is you
know which parts of all of us you know
you know we have bits of all of these
people in their lives and and so it's
really delicate you need an amazing
writing the amazing actors the amazing
director so that the intention is to get
to something deeper and more meaningful
without feeling like you're trying to
excuse-excuse it and and he's also
ridiculous you know and so there's a
humor in it to that cat this show is
able to capture and Corral I guess the
last thing I'll say is I think the cast
and Carell was vital in all of this you
know which is that he was a really is a
really brave actor and a brilliant actor
and there was a very conscious intent
from the beginning which is that to have
someone like Steve who an audience loves
admires and thinks of as their friend
and is their uncle and someone they just
can't imagine would have done these bad
things you know and so we were trying to
very much echo the experience people
have watching some of their most beloved
people learning these horrible things
about them and so you could go on that
journey go home with him and and see it
and doesn't excuse it but it allows you
to be there and take it in and then go
on this ride and then when you really
see what happened you really you know
distressed by it you know and and then
that experience it's to earn that
episode with Gugu the flashback episode
las vegas nestor your character Yanko
who's the weatherman he is one of the
things that I've said earlier this
evening that I love about the show is it
rushes into these gray areas it doesn't
just you know not avoid them it it
rushes into them and you know Yanko is
in a relationship with a subordinate
played by Belle Polly who plays Claire
is her name so when you know when yangko
Claire had their scenes together it was
very important that Yenko not seem like
a predator even though he is older and
he's famous and he's a big deal on the
show how did you and Belle navigate
those scenes together and what kind of
conversations did you two have about
their relationship that's a great
question I mean it it really it's it's a
bit more about the writing though in
terms of what Kari was conceiving in
terms of this dynamic and how did it
start and then there's a flashback scene
in Episode eight I believe which is sort
of the genesis of this relationship
where she approaches my Yanko Claire
approaches Yenko off the heels of
watching him to weathercast in puerto
rico and it's so she's really initiating
at the dynamic where as my character
sort of sort of falls into this thing
that she initiates and and I think a lot
of it was about intention about
motivation about and so I spoke with
Belle about this like how did we meet
you know that's that's and we sort of
created a loose history among ourselves
like you know even before we shot that
scene because it was important for it to
be a pure love it as you said it
couldn't be something that was sort of
lecherous on his part and being a
subordinate and and I did that you know
and the fact that he's a lot older than
her as well obviously plays into it so
so yeah it was important for us to come
up with something sort of pure and
innocent and that we've fallen into and
then just by the sheer fact that those
things are problematic in a work space
there's a conflict but but we had to
play against that conflict as much as we
could by keeping it as pure and innocent
as possible Brian probably nobody in the
world knows more about the news business
and particularly the TV news industry
than you and what what so much of this
show is about
besides being about power it is it's
about the news media and it's about the
you know news responsibility to hold the
powerful accountable and that is
something that has become more and more
difficult for the media to do at a time
when the
world is so divisive and everybody can
tune into whatever you know website or
network will tell them what they want to
hear and you know journalists are being
called the enemy you know by the leader
of our country what do you think the
media needs to do in order to try to do
its job and try to do the thing that it
was supposed to do against all of these
obstacles first of all I want to make
you my TV agent because you are very
flattering
I am grateful look everybody on
television right the brat the bradley's
and Alex's of the world of the morning
show you see a vulnerability and an
insecurity in those characters I mean
not not to mention you know this
disgraced former anchor has been taken
down all of them are so insecure so
vulnerable and yet that is what makes
them so appealing to the viewers so
relatable so powerful and I think we
show power dynamics in different ways on
this show and we talked about in one
level the me2 movement and those power
dynamics but also who has the power on
air is that the anchors or the producers
is that the anchors or the executives
who has the power to shape narratives
and tell you what is true in the world I
love how this season begins with Bradley
at a protest covering a protest for a
conservative news channel and then the
debates that she gets into with people I
love early in the season the
conversation among these eka tips about
what news is in this entertainment
saturated world because those are real
conversations that are actually
happening in in newsrooms and in media
companies and if you think about what's
happened the past three months
like I'm here in my spare bedroom I got
a camera behind me because this is the
studio or me and my wife do live shots
for TV like everything has gone upside
down in the last three months and I
think in some ways that's helped with
transparency with the viewers I think in
in real world media real world news the
more honest and transparent and
relatable we can be the better and
morning shows do that more effectively
than anything else you know when you're
watching Savannah Guthrie or Robin
Roberts or Gayle King you know you're
inside their world like no other time of
day like no other form of media
that's why this show is so relatable and
so compelling for people as well because
everybody wants to know what it was
really like for a for a male anchor who
was fired they want to know what it was
like for that person at home afterwards
they want to know what it was like for
the staff afterwards and you know Carrie
and me me and my everyone's dramatized
this and let people see behind the
curtain in a way that no other show ever
has Mimi was there a was there a
particular sequence or scene that when
you think back on the first season was
particularly challenging to get exactly
right there were you know there are so
many difficult conversations and
characters there are so many
interactions between people gosh I mean
I could you know the scenes between you
know Bradley and Hannah alone
but tell me one that was particularly
tricky to get right and how you did it
well there were so many that were
challenging I would you know say the
scene where I would say the scene where
Bradley is at the protest was an
extremely challenging scene it was
Reese's actually I think her first scene
that she shot so there we were in the in
the middle you know in this kind of
dirty mind
you know degree weather trying to figure
out the levels of anger the levels of
emotion the measure and the level of how
much this character loses how far does
this character go and you know when I
when an actor first hits fit you know
puts their feet in their shoes they're
just you know they're just touching you
know just trying to figure who at who
they are and so it was a big challenge
to throw her in and have her scream at
this guy and call him out and it was you
know one of her Achilles heels and that
she this was the thing that has held her
back and her
career this is character and so it was
really hard to in the middle of 300
extras to modulate that performance but
you know she's a brilliant actress and
we worked really hard on it and we found
it and it was really challenging and Jen
Aniston's first scene that she did in
the in the in the season was her last
scene in the pilot where she goes to
Mitch's house and she also had to go you
know ninety a hundred you know miles an
hour and and also find those grace notes
and also find the quiet and all the
stuff between the lines and so the you
know the material is very challenging
it's brilliantly written we you know
it's such a gift this show that you know
Brian gave us and this world that we are
peeling all these layers of and you know
we have Nestor we have all these
brilliant actors Jen and Rhys and DeSean
and Mark Duplass Billy cut up I know I'm
leaving someone out you know karen
pittman Gugu mbatha-raw and it's it's
just it's a joy to come to work and say
okay what are we gonna figure out today
how are we gonna get to the center of
this scene how you know what does this
scene about and and it's and it's just
been you know really challenging and and
really fun you know finding these
details and telling this you know
showing this world and the messiness and
how complicated it is and how we all are
and if I can just add to that when I
wrote my book about Maureen TV many
years ago like I came away loving these
shows even more like yes there was drama
yes there were there were scandals and
intrigue but I came away loving the
shows and appreciating the shows even
more and when you know you brought up
just you know enemy of the people
rhetoric outrageous and hateful things
said by the President and other
politicians in this environment we're in
the real world one way to combat those
lies and smears is by showing who we are
showing the people showing the real
people and I think what this show does
it dramatizes what it's writ for real
journalists what the real pressures are
but the real tensions are between you
know straight vanilla news and
entertainment like that kind of
conversation that kind of attention is
what disproves enemy of the people lies
that kind of demonstration of how
newsrooms really work is what counters
those smears in MB and what but what
nimi is neglected to say which is
instrumental in executing this is
creating an environment so that someone
like you know you know when you have a
scene like they were Bradley you know
the Reese's first scene or Jen's first
seniors seems insurmountable for anyone
to tackle that scene is let alone for
that to be the first scene is that you
have someone set this stage you know
like like Mimi
to have a relaxed environment and that
is just it's very hard to do for any
director and I remember talking to Belle
about this we had a tough scene our
first one aversive first things was
tough and it was like I felt every time
I talked to you me it was almost like I
felt like there was also a therapist
there you know and into you create this
beautiful environment that allows for
actors to to let go and trust you know
and just be there and and that is the
truth I mean that that's what I mean
among many other things that you do
beautifully that's just instrumental
into any scene is to is to have
everyone's guard down and just to be raw
and honest and that certainly this show
is a show called for it whenever you
work with Carriere and you're gonna be
called to be as raw as you can be in you
set the stage for that and that's that
was huge to have you there at the helm
is enormous okay what is happening right
now with the show are you is everybody
in the writers room but working remotely
where are we
yes the writers are working remotely and
you know it's a new the new normal and
we are you know we were in the middle of
shooting the first episode when we shut
down and you know we're you know working
all the kovat protocols and figuring out
how to go back to work safely
and that's what we're in the middle of
doing and fine-tuning our scripts is
everybody shooting for like early I know
the you know probably ideally the second
season would have started in November
are you thinking now maybe early 2021
you mean when you and I will see it oh
yeah what else when you'll be done and
it'll air yeah I mean I mean yeah
there's the yeah I don't think we'll be
able to finish shooting this year but
the you'll have talked to Apple
obviously about when when when will air
be back all right well a lot of those
like that yeah I can't wait it thank you
all of you Nestor Carbonell me me leader
Michael elenberg brian Stelter and thank
you we're out of time but thank you for
everybody who joined in and listen
thanks to the actors and producers for
taking time to come on and answer our
question then thank you Apple TV plus
for making it all happen and including
me in it everybody stay safe and stay
healthy
bye thank you thank you Jess this is
dramatic thrilling
you stole my life with this you left me
in the woods with a pack of wolves this
is an important story what if that takes
down the network show and everybody on
it it's not a risk worth taking
[Music]
get on this ride it's gonna be a good
one
[Music]